la vicepresidenta estadounidense de
kamala harris tiene una nueva misión
tratar de frenar el flujo de migrantes
desde centroamérica hacia su país la
tarea le fue encomendada este 24 de
marzo por el mandatario joe biden
la vicepresidenta acordó entre muchas
otras cosas y lo agradezco liderar
nuestro esfuerzo diplomático y trabajar
con esas naciones para aceptar a los
repatriados y mejorar la aplicación de
la ley de migración en sus fronteras
tras asumir el nombramiento harris
reconoció que se trata de un panorama
complejo ante el que resulta clave
abordar la violencia y la corrupción que
llevan a los migrantes
debemos abordar las causas fundamentales
que hacen que las personas hagan la
caminata para venir aquí y espero
participar en las acciones diplomáticas
con el gobierno el sector privado la
sociedad civil y los líderes del
salvador guatemala y honduras
en los últimos meses el aumento de la
migración irregular ha llevado al
sistema de acogida estadounidense al
borde del colapso lo cual le ha valido
duras críticas al gobierno de bailén la
oposición republicana enviará una misión
a la frontera para darle visibilidad a
lo que califican como una crisis
humanitaria de la cual culpan a las
políticas de la nueva administración
a los 63 coaching son las políticas de
joe biden las que están causando el
abuso de estos niños crimen
no es compasión y no es humano hondo
life y vamos aquí para arrojar luz sobre
las vidas y la tragedia humana las
políticas de inmigración fallidas de
bailén y la crisis fronteriza de bailén
las miradas siguen puestas sobre la
situación de los menores que han cruzado
la frontera y que permanecen en los
centros de protección se estima que al
menos 15 mil siguen en albergues que el
actual gobierno pretende ampliar